[Musik]
hanni lemon schicken oder eine grüne
smoothie ball bei instagram geht es
appetit anregen zu perfekt inszenierte
food fotos in der trend im netz eines
der top motive balls also schüsseln mit
möglichst vielen bunten zutaten darin
die gibt es in der die long legs in
münchen auch analog gesunde gerichte im
hochwertige optik gehören zum konzept
des kaffees man weiß hat es vor drei
jahren eröffnet
und so kunden haben einen großen
anspruch an die bulls dass die schön
aussehen dass die vor allem instagram
fähig sind und das ist sehr sehr wichtig
empfunden dass die boards ansprechend
aussehen und manche suchen sich extra
viele dopings aus die persönlich fällt
auf das essen einfach ein mediales
erlebnis geworden ist hier stehen
smoothies und bulls auf der karte das
was bei jungen groß steht dann gerade
gefragt ist erdbeeren stein besonders
schön neben frischer mango baby spinat
neben wurzelgemüse es geht nicht nur um
den geschmack und die zutaten es geht
auch um die kunst des arrangieren uns
von essen
wir versuchen natürlich alles ja so ein
bisschen symmetrisch auch hinzulegen
also bananenscheiben hat im gleichen
abstand zu leben schon aufzufächern
rhein zu bilden zum beispiel ist auch
immer ganz gut weg spielt eine große
rolle perfekt inszeniertes essen ist
links nicht mehr nur der
spitzengastronomie vorbehalten cafés und
restaurants treffen auf zunehmend
anspruchsvolle kunden und reagieren
schuld daran ist der trend zum food
borne eine der hashtags unter dem sich
hippe kulinarik fans kurz rudis auf
instagram überbieten längst gibt es
stars unter ihnen wie pauline borsdorf
aus berlin mittlerweile hat sie knapp
250.000 verloren
für ein shooting vorbereitet dann habe
ich auch immer schon so ein bisschen die
fotos die später erreichen möchte im
kopf das heißt ich überlege aus welchem
winkel möchte ich was fotografieren und
das beeinflusst natürlich auch manchmal
das styling oder das überhaupt erst die
formel ich bestimmte bestimmte
lebensmittel oder wie vor mir ich mein
essen
die 22-jährige ist hauptberuflich
foodbloggerin
geld verdient sie mit ihrem kochbuch und
durch sponsoring
kein leichter job visuell hochwertige
gerichte sind harte arbeit erst recht
wenn wir heute ein eigentlich eher
blasser spargel gurkensalat mit
kichererbsen und zum nachtisch hafer
kekse auf dem speiseplan stehen
durch die schöne darstellung macht es
bei manchen leuten klick und
wer-weiss-was welche sinne da irgendwie
berührt werden wenn wir uns essen
anschauen da passiert bestimmt noch
irgendwas im körper aber es macht
einfach spaß gerade wenn eben die
darstellung schön aussieht und ich habe
das gefühl dass gerade in der letzten
zeit essen noch mal eine andere
wertigkeit bekommen haben